self-consciousness exists in and for
itself when and by the fact that it so
exists for another that is it exists
only in being acknowledged the notion of
this its unity in its duplication
embraces many and varied meanings its
moments that must on the one hand be
strictly a part and on the other hand
must in this differentiation at the same
time also be taken and known as not
distinct or in their opposite
significance the twofold significance of
the distinct moments has in the nature
of self-consciousness to be infinite or
directly the opposite of the determinate
'no sin which it is posited the detailed
exposition of the notion of the
spiritual unity in its duplication will
present us with the process of
recognition
we've now arrived at paragraph 178 one
that I know that you've been looking
forward to all of you viewers in part
because it's a turning point for Hegel's
phenomenology and what we're going into
is the section that has been most often
looked at in isolation from the other
parts of the phenomenology what I'm
going to try to do as we go through this
is to keep on reconnecting it to the
rest of the phenomenology because I
think that's very important
so what section are we talking about
here it's translated in your in your
Millard translation has lordship and
bondage that's a common English
rendering for hair shaft and connect
half master and slave the master-slave
dialectic is just as good we don't need
to quibble about which of these terms is
the closer to the German because the
answer is really they're both you know
this is this is something that has been
talked about so much in Hegel literature
and both sets of terms have been used
you know pretty extensively so you don't
have to feel as if you have to stick
with one or the other and I'm going to
go back and forth myself most likely as
we do this now you'll notice that I've
got this first passage sort of charted
out with a bit of the German thrown in
there that you know is worth you know
commenting on and thinking about this
first this first sentence is very
important and so we're going to look at
that closely and then talk about what's
going on in the rest of this paragraph
this really sets the agenda for what is
to come throughout the entire section
because there's a key term here that
Hegel is bringing up and that is
recognized a recognition on Air Canada
this is what the master and the slave
what the two self-consciousness is are
striving for across this entire dynamic
that's developing between the two of
them and it's something that's going to
continue throughout the relationship of
individual self-consciousness or
individual self-consciousness within the
realm of spirit with other self
consciousnesses we're not actually going
to
to some sort of complete recognition
until the very very end of the
phenomenology when we go past religion
and we get into absolute knowing and we
talk about the spiritual community but
it's something that is at the core of
human desire remember how important
desire was for self consciousness but
geared a hunger desire what it is that
we're seeking you know craving what it
is that we're really craving deep down
inside according to Hegel besides food
and drink and security and things like
that
it is recognition by another recognition
that we cannot just enjoy for a fleeting
moment but which we can take as
something stable as in fact something
that we can be certain of you know we
want the truth and the certainty as
always recognition so Hegel is going to
say self-consciousness yes and your book
has exists the German is just yes so
either one is fine yeah in itself and
for itself right and this is something
that we've been looking for throughout
the entire development in the earlier
dynamic something that is both in itself
and for itself this is going to take on
a very important role can the
self-consciousness remain in itself and
for itself the entire time not as not as
we're going to see it happening but
that's what it's always striving for so
it's in itself and for itself there he's
got two terms that are translated here
as when and by the fact and so in name
and or right when not as in the temporal
sense but rather as sort of you know
this is the qualifier this says what the
conditions need to be and then there are
through through the fact that by the
fact through the condition that and what
is what is going on here what are what
is the what are these qualifying things
it's in itself and for itself when it is
in itself and for itself here's the key
thing
for another if I were to joke a little
bit here the solemn sister the
narcissist can't be a good hit galleon
right because they don't have another to
engage with but you know what you might
say well they don't have another to
engage with precisely because they
realize that others are so unreliable
and you can't predict what they're going
to do because they are also autonomous
self consciousness is you can't coerce
them into just being you know
accoutrement to your own little world if
you do that you lose out on we're gonna
see how that dynamic plays out but in
itself and for itself for another the
way that he talks about this then is
when and through the fact that it is
recognized alter their honor contest as
one who is recognized recognized by who
you might say well just by another right
but also recognition for oneself as
we're going to see is indeed mediated
through the other and you might say well
who's this other there's a whole world
of others out there and you know one
other is different than another other
and here's what's really interesting
about it you know the world doesn't
Center upon me and it doesn't Center on
any of those other others either it may
temporarily seem to do so but it doesn't
in fact and where the entire Hegelian
movement is going towards the end is
having this this whole expanse of self
consciousness is who are related to each
other they're connected and you might
say a whole web that goes all the way
back into human history and proceeds you
know further into the future in which no
single one individual is absolutely
transcendent precisely because every
individual is indeed recognized but
that's you know again further down the
line so let's continue with this if we
get past that first sentence here he
talks about how we have to make sense of
this and here he's giving us not some
you know the schema is not sort of
general resolution of the matter but
rather you might say some some guidance
about where we're going to go and how
we're going to get there so he says this
the notion of this its unity and its
duplication embraces many and varied
meanings right this is going to take
place through a whole bunch of different
shapes of consciousness as we're going
to see running throughout the rest of
the text
not just the master-slave dialectic by
the way the master-slave dialectic it's
at the beginning it's very important but
he's not saying this is the pattern for
all human interaction and some people
have taken him to be saying it's moments
that must on the one hand be held
strictly apart right the moments are
separated from each other what are the
moments the individual
self-consciousness and what is going on
in their development they have to be
held apart from each other and yeah on
the other hand must in this
differentiation at the same time also be
taken and known as not distinct so in
their differentiation and their wonder
shy of being splitting apart right as
not distinct not ultra shaped right not
not split apart from each other these
are he says opposed these these
significances gagging is Esteva though
I'm opposed you know set apart from each
other meanings right this has to be
taken in an opposite meaning from that
so he says the the you know the twofold
significance of the distinct moments has
in the nature of self-consciousness to
be infinite this whole thing is going on
within soft consciousness yes
self-consciousness is infinite in part
by not being able to be entirely what it
is like it's sort of closed in upon
itself fear to be self-conscious we saw
before with the the earlier part of this
section involves this reflexivity you
can look at yourself right you can take
a stance upon yourself but it also does
so precisely by this relation to another
and we saw that the most interesting
other is not the plant is not the
the you know external world is not the
landscape is not the animal even its the
other self-consciousness that can in
some way make itself an object for us
and which as we're going to see can
objectify us as well that is what is is
there in the infinity of
self-consciousness so he says he goes
out I says the detailed exposition of
the notion of the spiritual unity in its
duplication will present us with the
process of recognition that's what we're
up to in the rest of this section
self-consciousness is faced by another
self-consciousness it has come out of
itself this has a two-fold significance
first it has lost itself for it finds
itself as and other being secondly in
doing so it is superseded the other for
it does not see the other as an
essential being but in the other sees
its own self
like many of the shorter paragraphs that
we've seen leading up to this point
paragraph 179 has one central idea that
is worth exploring we don't have to go
into great depth about it because it's
exploration is going to happen in the
paragraphs that follow but it but it is
worth stressing this point so Hegel says
what we have now is a self-consciousness
that has gone outside of itself it is
you know now in the world so to speak at
the very least I would side of its own
head we might say outside of its own its
own you know boundedness of its own
heart it's a fact and it is connected
with an other but this other is also a
self-consciousness so he says it's faced
by another self-consciousness and he
says this is a twofold significance
we're going to see this twofold
coming up quite a bit especially in the
paragraphs that follow right after this
where Hegel is going to talk about
ambiguity and what is the twofold
significance at this point there's a
sort of I don't want to say bifurcation
but rather a mixing together of two
different experiences two different
attitudes and both of these are going on
at the same time in the relation to the
other self-consciousness so
self-consciousness desires ultimately to
be recognized by this other
self-consciousness and thereby to
recognize itself what happens Hegel says
well let's let's go directly to the text
here he says it has lost itself
self-consciousness has launched itself
in the other why it finds easy itself as
another being by seeing the
self-consciousness by seeing itself over
there the the other has you might say
you know certain sums appropriated
without even meaning to do so the
identity or the essence of the itself
over here remember self-consciousness
right it is a relation
a reflexive relation with itself and so
you know when I think about Who I am you
know and what my importance is and how I
matter what it is that I am down at the
core I can have these experiences where
I discover I'm not so special that you
know there to be a great example I go to
a club because I want to find other
people who share my particular interest
and before I enter into that door I am
the guy who does this I am the guy who
is interested in this I am the guy who
can talk about that let me get to the
club and I find somebody else and I can
talk back and forth of them and I have
that moment of recognition oh it's so
great today actually have somebody who
is interested in medieval history and
then it turns out that they know a lot
more about medieval history than I do
and suddenly the weight has gone over to
that side or they don't even need to net
need necessarily to know more they just
need to know a bit more or even the same
as I this is just one example out of so
many that we could we could use now at
the same time in addition to this loss
we also have something like a Super
Session and out of Heilong the other
self-consciousness he says in doing so
it is superseded the other four it does
not see the other as an essential being
but in the other sees its own self so
there's this this double-sided miss to
seeing the self in the other whether the
other is a rival whether the other is a
friend whether the other is a lover
whether the other is a teacher you know
we could pick whatever role we want this
duality is inhabiting it in the relation
of self consciousness to another self
consciousness
it must supersede this other nosov
itself this is the Super Session of the
first ambiguity and is therefore itself
a second ambiguity first it must proceed
to supersede the other independent being
in order thereby to become certain of
itself as the essential being secondly
in so doing it proceeds to supersede its
own self for this other is itself
there's two key terms here in Section 80
that are being used in a way almost
correlative to each other and I suppose
it's a little bit funny that we're
talking about twos here because one of
those very terms has the whole sense of
duality built within it and that is this
this ambiguity right when we have an
ambiguity or in German doubles in double
cents double meaning what we've got
going on is one thing that it can be
interpreted in multiple ways here are
Hegel's thinking in terms of two ways
but you know true ambiguity of the
things could be all over the place like
the word seal for example is if the the
the rock singer is that the animal is it
the thing that you you know have to seal
something up is that the action that's
an ambiguous some what might say an
equivocal term and if we're using it in
a situation in which it could be
interpreted multiple ways in which we're
not getting enough context cues then we
have an ambiguity there and often times
ambiguity is unavoidable as in this
entire case we saw that the first
ambiguity has to do with the fact that
the other self-consciousness is the
other of the self so that you know going
back to the previous paragraph if it's
regarded as an independent being what
does that mean for self-consciousness a
loss of itself in the other the other
takes on the you might say the pole of
essential T in this this dynamic
relationship on the other hand insofar
as the other can be seen as just another
self as being the same as the self it
becomes an unofficial being because I'm
seeing that other self over there and
I'm the one who's seeing it so I'm the
essential being and that is what Hegel
calls the first super session he just
called it the super session in the
previous paragraph but now he's calling
it the first because he's talking about
two of them so the first super session
has to do with this first ambiguity the
fact that I can see the other and
another of me as myself being there in
the other as the the similarity between
us in two different ways two distinct
ways that cannot be separated apart from
each other I'm stuck sir feeling these
and living through these both at the
same time that's why the other ends up
being the other to me that's that's part
of the experience of the other so then
he goes on and he says self
consciousness must supersede this other
nests of itself
what is superseding this other nests of
itself well that's this super session
here the super session of the first
ambiguity
therefore itself becomes a second
ambiguity connected with a second super
session a super session of the super
session going up to yet a higher level
what's happening very quickly here isn't
it so he says I must proceed to
supersede the other independent being in
or it's become certain of itself as the
essential being in doing so here's the
second super session it proceeds to
supersede its own self because when it's
superseding the other the other is its
own self if I am superseding the other
Who I am sort of threatened by or you
know I don't want to become the
essential one if they I've asserted
myself against that person I am actually
doing something to myself over there in
that other person at the same time it
was the fact that I am over there which
meant that the other could become the
essential one which then you know gave
me some sort of anxiety or troubling or
whatever that led me to supersede them
but then itself ends up superseding me
in the process so there is a double
ambiguity here Hegel says there's two
different ambiguities there's an
ambiguity of ambiguity if you're like
that if you want to you know play around
with that idea then and that is
something that is integral to the
relation to the other self consciousness
this ambiguous Super Session of it's
ambiguous other nests is equally an
ambiguous return into itself for first
through the Super Session it receives
back its own self because by superseding
its other nests it again becomes equal
to itself but secondly the other
self-consciousness equally gives it back
again to itself for its saw itself in
the other but supersedes this being of
itself in the other and thus let's the
other again go free
paragraph
one begins with a very difficult and
confusing sentence which invokes
ambiguity three different times and so
it is very important to understand
what's going on here
I wanted to chart it out for you so you
can see exactly what Hegel is talking
about you have to think back to the
previous paragraphs that we've just gone
over for the reference points about the
what the ambiguity constitutes notice I
didn't say reference points I said
referent because we're thinking about
what we're referring to right the
reference of that and let's just read
through the sentence and then I'll lead
you through it so he says this ambiguous
supersession right it's ambiguous other
Ness is equally an ambiguous returning
to itself so we've got three different
ambiguities seemingly the two of the
ambiguities are actually signs of the
same thing we talked about the ambiguous
supersession in the past paragraph we
talked about two super sessions which
are actually the same super session but
you can look at them in different ways
the first and the second that is the
ambiguity that we're talking about there
in the ambiguous supersession over here
on this side ambiguous other Ness what
do we mean by that well ambiguous other
Ness meant that I am finding myself in
the other as self-consciousness because
the other has a self-consciousness a
similar structure to myself and we saw
that I can I can be losing myself in the
other self-consciousness or I can sort
of regain myself by superseding them so
the first super session is of the other
as other or the other that is sort of
taken over the you know the the center
of importance the other has become the
center point of the world and I take
that back from them so I can have it
myself but then the the joke's on me
because as it turns out I'm over there
in the other and in superseding the
other precisely because I'm superseding
the other because I
you know they there's a risk to me by
the fact that I'm over there I'm
superseding myself in the other and so
in a way I win by losing and I lose by
winning there's really interesting you
know switch between polarities here that
we're gonna see plants off about as we
move into other paragraphs so so far
it's so good right we have an ambiguous
Super Session we now know what the
ambiguity is of ambiguous other nests we
now know what that ambiguity is so he
says this leads to an ambiguous return
into itself this is a whole thing here
all right so what is this ambiguous
returning to itself that's the rest of
this this paragraph there's two sides to
it right when we see ambiguity for Hegel
we should think okay we're looking for
two things going on at the same time two
different interpretations that are that
are in a certain sense harmonious but
also jarring with each other what are
they so self consciousness receives back
its own selfishness in this supersession
why it supersedes the others right and
thereby becomes equal to itself again
which is part of what it was looking for
self consciousness is looking for self
certainty and it has self certainty by
knowing what in fact it is right by
being able to say I am this turns out
unfortunately that tends to be rather
content less and doesn't satisfy us for
very very long that's going to be an
issue right it also receives itself from
the other self consciousness Hegel talks
about the other self consciousness given
here so he says secondly the other self
consciousness equally gives it back
again to itself gives self consciousness
itself back to itself so the other is
playing a active role here something
that I can't myself control something
that I can't in a certain sense predict
even precisely because it is another
self conscious
so this is where we're talking about
recognition right recognition cannot be
ultimately coerced not if you want real
recognition so it receives itself from
the other self-consciousness who was
giving it why because it superseded the
being of itself and the other that was
the second that was the second Super
Session right in the ambiguity there
when Hegel says is this means that it
lets the other go free this is very
momentous this is a very important point
the other as a self-consciousness is
going to be free and that sounds really
great how freedom is wonderful for
everybody until you see how people
actually use their freedom and you
started thinking about well what the
hell are they going to do with it you
know I might do this or that
well they might do something even
crazier than me so the other going free
is in a certain sense of achievement but
it's also going to lead to what we're
going to see happen in the nests of Oh
paragraphs
you